[Music]
it must be great to be Batman
thank you I'm blushing super hard under
the mask going home right now the party
the night away surrounded my brand and
lady activewear models master Bruce your
greatest fear is snakes no Stiles no
it's being a part of a family again
no now it's snake Klaus because you put
that idea in my head sir you need to
take responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising the young orphan you
adopt Lee I thought I was being
sarcastic
answer just a little tight I got an idea
I can only look you in the eyes right
now
[Music]
Superman is my greatest enemy can I say
that I don't currently have a bad guy I
am fighting a few different people I
like to fight around hi Barbara Gordon
new police commissioner it's my dream
the police force to team up with Batman
what wouldn't it be better I hate
everything you just said
initialized master Billy we did it
pretty cool huh
why did you build this thing with only
one seat because last I checked I only
had one but let's go defeat the Joker I
can wear my costume Jim well luckily for
us you left your costume backing right
oh no under your clothes that's perfect